En este tercer vídeo quiero ver
más ejemplos de problemas de funciones,
además me gustaría presentarte una idea bonita.
Mira, ya vimos
dos formas en las cuales podemos definir funciones,
una es a través de una igualdad,
con una expresión algebraica
y la otra es a partir de casos,
o sea,
esto era más o menos
como cuando decíamos que la función valía algo,
si "x" era impar y valía otra cosa si "x" era par.
Pero hay una tercera forma en la cual podemos definir una función y es a partir de una gráfica,
déjame pasar aquí abajo.
Y para esta idea de la gráfica,
vamos a necesitar un par de ejes,
aquí los tengo dibujados.
Ahí están los ejes,
tenemos un eje horizontal y un eje vertical
y la idea es que aquí en esta gráfica
vamos a pintar un puntito,
si a un cierto valor
en el eje "x",
esto de aquí es el eje "x"
le corresponde un cierto valor "f" de "x"...
valor "f" de "x".
Entonces déjame poner algunos puntitos aquí
y ahorita vemos específicamente a qué me refiero.
Voy a poner un punto aquí arriba en
a altura 2,
aquí en el -5 a altura 2
en el -4 a altura -1
también -1
lo voy a marcar un poco más
y también va a ser -1...
Estoy marcando algunos puntos
y estos puntos nos van a indicar
el valor de la función.
Entonces voy a poner unos cuantos más...
ya casi terminó,
voy a poner nada más este de acá.
Ok,
entonces además de esos puntos
déjame trazar algunas líneas que los unan,
este vaya aquí para acá,
estos quedan unidos así,
esto así,
esto va para acá
y luego esto va a para acá,
más o menos,
bueno este puntito déjame ponerlo
un poco más abajo,
ahí está.
Ok entonces aquí tenemos una gráfica
y puedes decir, oye esa gráfica se ve como,
muy chistosa y muy rara
y bueno sí,
en efecto sí se ve chistosa y rara,
pero la cosa es que esta gráfica,
nos permite definir una función
de la siguiente manera.
Si tomamos un cierto valor de "x"
que esté entre menos 5 y 5,
esta línea nos va a decir
cuánto es "f" de "x", observando la altura.
Por ejemplo, si estamos aquí en el -5
si tomamos el valor -5,
entonces la función evaluada en el -5,
va a ser igual a 2
porque aquí está a la altura 2
¿vale?
Déjame hacer algunos otros,
por ejemplo ¿qué pasa con 0?
Ah, pues en 0 la línea esta a altura 0,
entonces "f" de 0...
"f" de 0,
es igual a 0.
De manera similar "f" de 1,
es igual a -1,
por aquí está el 1 y este al -1
"f" de 1 es igual a -1,
creo que se ve la idea verdad.
Básicamente tomamos un punto y nos vamos a la línea,
para ver el valor de la función.
Bueno, entonces ésta es una forma gráfica de definir una función,
y a partir de esta función,
y otras más vamos a resolver algunos ejemplos.
Pensemos que además de esta función "f",
también nos dan una función "g" de "x",
definida así,
como "g" de "x",
es igual a "f" de "x"
elevado al cuadrado.
Para que no sea confuso,
voy a poner aquí un paréntesis,
es primero, encontrar "f" de "x"
y luego elevar eso al cuadrado,
y además tenemos que restar "f" de "x".
Entonces ésta es la definición de "g"
y tenemos una tercera función
que se llama "h" de "x",
y está definida como 3 menos "x".
Muy bien,
entonces teniendo estas tres funciones,
imagínate que nos piden determinar...
le voy a poner "h" de "g" de -1.
¿Cómo le haríamos para determinar esto?
pues es la misma idea
que en los vídeos anteriores.
Primero determinamos,
cuánto es "g" de -1,
entonces vamos a hacer "g" de -1,
por aquí abajito.
Entonces "g" de -1.
"g" de -1es igual a,
pues simplemente,
este -1 lo sustituimos en cada aparición de "x",
entonces este -1 aquí diría -1,
nos quedaría "f" de -1,
esto elevado al cuadrado,
menos "f" de -1
y ahora tenemos que ver cuánto es "f" de -1,
pero para saber quién es "f" de -1
tenemos que ir a la gráfica.
entonces por aquí está el -1
y el "f" de -1 es igual a 1 ¿vale?
"f" de -1 es igual a 1.
De esta forma, este "f" de -1 es igual a un 1,
nos queda 1 al cuadrado
este también es un 1,
que da 1 al cuadrado menos 1
y estoy aquí es igual a 0,
¿vale?
entonces "g" de -1 es igual a 0,
y ahora podemos sustituir este valor aquí arriba,
para ver cuánto es "h" de "g" de -1,
entonces esto de aquí, "h" de "g" de -1
sería igual
a "h"
de 0,
y "h" de 0,
usando esta definición,
la de "h" de "x",
"h" de 0 es igual a 3menos 0,
y eso es igual a 3.
Muy bien, entonces ya tenemos que,
"h" de "g" de -1 es igual a 3.
Vamos a hacer otro ejemplo,
pero antes un consejo,
si te atoras un poquito en estos problemas,
te recomiendo volver a ver el video,
pero pausarlo en el momento
en el cual yo escribo el ejercicio.
Eso te va a permitir intentarlo por tu cuenta,
y ya después puedes ponerle reproducir
para ver si hicimos lo mismo
y si obtuvimos el mismo resultado.
Bueno, entonces vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
lo voy a volver a utilizar esta función "f",
para no graficar, éste... otra función,
pero déjame cambiar las funciones "g" y "h",
bueno,
de hecho nada más voy a poner una función.
Entonces, imagínate que ahora nos dicen que "g" de "x",
éste ya es otro problema, eh,
"g" de "x" es igual...
es igual a "f" de "x" al cuadrado,
más, le voy a poner
"f" de "x" más 2 ¿vale?
entonces esto de aquí es "g" de "x"
y ahora lo que nos piden determinar
es el valor de "g" de -2,
vamos a ponerle "g" de -2.
Muy bien entonces,
¿cómo le hacemos?
pues misma idea,
sustituimos todas las "x"
que tenemos aquí por -2,
entonces tendríamos "f" de -2 al cuadrado,
más "f" de -2 más 2,
simplemente
simplificamos un poco estas expresiones,
nos queda igual a,
"f" de 4,
más "f" de 0
y recuerda,
para obtener los valores de "f",
lo que tenemos que hacer es
consultar esta gráfica de acá.
Entonces vamos a ver, cuánto es "f" de 4,
entonces tenemos, 1, 2, 3, 4
por aquí está el 4
y la altura,
a la cual estamos en 4 es 2,
entonces "f" de 4 es igual a 2,
y "f" de 0,
bueno, pues "f" de 0 es 0 ¿verdad?
Aquí está, "f" 0 es igual a 0
entonces nos quedaría igual,
a 2 más 0,
y por lo tanto,
"g" de -2 es igual a 2.
Muy bien, entonces como ves,
estos problemas están realmente interesantes,
algo que te recomiendo,
es que sigas jugando con algunos ejemplos.
Tú inventate tus propios problema
s e intenta evaluar las funciones,
en ciertos valores,
y eso te va a ayudar
muchísimo para practicar.
De hecho, otra cosa que estaría interesante,
es ver cómo es la gráfica de esta función "g",
o sea que esta función "g",
intentar meterla ahí al plano,
bueno a aquí a los ejes.
Entonces, bueno,
si quieres puedes pensar acerca de eso,
a lo mejor después lo hagamos en otro vídeo.
Ahorita... ahorita creo que ya no tengo tanto tiempo para intentar otro ejemplo,
así que lo dejaremos para el siguiente vídeo,
pero la idea es
seguir haciendo varios ejercicios de funciones,
para que te acostumbres a esta idea
y veas que es muy muy versátil
y que tiene muchas aplicaciones.
Bueno,
nos vemos hasta la próxima y diviértete.